wendy williams who is putting it all out
there on the table in her new biopic
which airs this weekend the drugs the
cheating her plastic surgery
none of it was off limits in our
exclusive interview including questions
about if her show is coming to an end i
love doing this but i'm realistic and i
know it's not going to last forever
i would like to go into the classroom i
would like to be a professor
not a lecturer for one day but teach a
course
in the communications department okay so
wendy's not quitting daytime anytime
soon but she does have plenty of other
projects going on
including executive producing her new
lifetime documentary
and biopic it reveals everything
including
personal heartbreak i was shocked by the
miscarriages being that pregnant and
then losing a baby and having to give
birth
twice yeah yeah and then having to go
home and clean up the nursery
how hard were those days very hard
especially because i knew that kevin was
cheating on me at that time you know
this girl who had his baby is not the
only one
and it was shortly after we got married
that i found that out
have you ever cheated me again kevin i
swear
and i promise you you will lose me i had
pis
on him and on her i knew
exactly where her gyn was i had my
people follow them on vacations
if we didn't have children i would have
been out
wendy's still trying to heal after
losing her mom shirley
her live tv revelation last month went
viral
and wendy says it was awkward for a
reason
she also talked me into picking out this
outfit today
she's also died
yeah i had to process it myself because
i was the one who got the call in the
morning from the doctor and
he said um you know we tried
we tried we tried
that's a hard call to get it's a hard
moment
yeah and i still came to work she passed
away
beautiful and peacefully and surrounded
by love
in the biopic premiering saturday the 56
year old
also dives into her own body image
issues
so let's talk about these breasts yes
doctor i want them that big
i fluctuate between 148 pounds and 155
pounds
i weighed that in sixth grade
i always knew that i was going to get
fixed through
surgery i promised myself that once i
got
it all done i would never
eat my way back to where i came from
health-wise how are you doing because
you look really good i feel fine i'm
doing very very
well i've got a very good team of
doctors i take a thyroid pill and a loon
zest
every day and that's it wendy says she's
single now and has strict
dating requirements my next boyfriend
hopefully husband he'll turn into um i
don't want to be in this business
he's got to appreciate my humor and have
a sense of humor for the business that
i'm in
and not try to stop me
you